miguel monteiro esse garoto hall me
perguntar eu não como está melhorando a
lusa
eu digo do dólar porque tenho gasto fora
do kosovo não pode ser ainda não pode
não pode ser jogada do gol e não é o
juro de dor e 1950 escreveram ninguém
assume a bola para que fosse boa hora
foi boa então não acho legal o terceiro
encontro era burro vai ter desculpa
desculpa 000 mortes
uma vez peguei o que está a fazer e
ainda ajudar o mal e só que eu falei
olha foi pedro miranda foi para dormir
já damião foi em 2000 anunciou os
foi cantado a minha legal foi criado o
campeonato do mundo logo a questão vai
ser a questão foi que meu deus o decreto
impressão digital olha só a proibição
fica aqui não é isso eu acho que na era
telê será que dessa vez ele pode ir lá
dentro o ala emerson danesi amiga ontem
o scan meu deus miguel tem namorada é
muito lindo o flamengo não mais vigente
pela amiga glória experimentaste a
cobertura está feito ea culpa é mais
fácil um milhão a milhão saiu porque
lutaram não me inteiro eu voltei eu
volto ou deixa assim no texto permite o
envio piancelli boyle foi a o preto eo
branco a trave e eu não tenho como me go
go boy é de miguel monteiro está frio aí
não quero ninguém descobriu o milhão não
têm a minha câmera ficou branca mas
pagar por isso
a standard poor s melhor do que quando
você precisa mesmo
sob o capô miguel manter uma aventura
história começa toda me a tudo que
cercou e não fazer a minha roteiro bem e
eu notei colégio barão aula bem como a
discutir no setup miguel monteiro que é
melhor manter em agosto no rádio porque
ajudaram um solo disse olha o lance
checheno ao perceber que o estágio mas
vou ganhar um único jogo que era o jogo
não se sabe o que é isso aí galera fez o
que fez pela luta
miguel monteiro fez muitos brinquedos e
química muito sério mas traz um canal
brinquedos e hobbies construir qualquer
coisa que vai ter porque o padre miguel
monteiro braga o dinheiro distribuído
por ter muito lá e muito lá e montar
apostas da área posso dar uma mãozinha
mel postar uma mãozinha ou teclado está
funcionando não está a funcionar miguel
e luciana godoi which miguel tem sua
origem no quarto eu nunca falei que ela
cuidou eu já estaria é o fuso horário é
mais um sonho
miguel monteiro de michael no meio eu
não tenho de continuar esse barrigão não
pode punir um jogo brigado participou de
um jogo a toalha ao estatuto é uma
vontade clara de telemóvel e ao tomar
uma rápida perda de tempo legal não
estaria mais seguro assim é tornar os
seus contactos podem colocar a chave
para evitar que ela vai ser a única
coisa que eu me torne tão legal manter o
windows a montar o espaço e miguel
monteiro caps fácil passar tudo miguel
couto de que já não tenha razão miguel e
agora eu não tenho está chateado mesmo
tempo está triste eu sou um bem material
miguel monteiro e tem conceito tem um
que o euro registra olha isso aqui está
tudo bom vez miguel dá para utilizar
esse pode ser um tapete olha só eu acho
que já provei isso ajudou o miguel
monteiro
muito irritado joel é conseguiu tudo
miguel monteiro o time está se ajeitando
tudo fizesse contra o mesmo desculpa
mesmo calma calma miguel calmon é só um
vídeo miguel monteiro não eficaz de
fugas mas eu ajudar o pio dark vai fazer
o mesmo comigo para tudo e não tá meio
chateado portanto eu vou fazer uma
surpresa eu já sabia que o irmão era um
monitor de oficina então o que eu vou
fazer eu vou exercer o meu monitor ou
pista que este monitor
eu sempre quis ter um monitor assim
muito grande que tem 7 polegadas
portanto envolve ser o meu eu não vou
usar também portanto eu posso ser
tranquilo eu acho que é o mínimo que eu
posso fazer tanto olhar o seu monitor
eu não tenho o que posso e gauther eu
tenho aqui uma surpresa ainda mantém o
lance
então eu chorar uai
olha aí pra eu tenho de superar o time
tornou a celebridade chorar hora lembrei
muito não olha eu acho que ele perdeu o
primeiro posto mas foi o sporting quem
olha é isso é muito maior ganha
manteigas galló em dinheiro
não não sei do que ele é monitorar e ele
é bonita pra jogar lo o feito também
estou bem grande amiga manteiga aí cada
mulher a adobe funciona e submisso
senhora funciona no térreo funciona é é
ainda monitora amiga matéria agora é só
mandar para a china e não não não teria
nem de obrigado obrigado dito isso aqui
você tem tudo isso enquanto não milhão
turismo agradecer melhor altura em que
miguel tá tudo sujeito que atualmente
ensina a transformar o quarto ea matéria
foi ofertado bonito cinco jogos o
hipnótico todos com cinco jogos e na
outra uma das mais belas cinco filhos
pode fazer miguel em estado de vargas
ferreira docente pular e assumirá no
próximo mês no windows basta que a
empresa portuguesa vai mostrar às
mulheres que queiram ficar assim o
quarto é do windows do casal já sabem
que só inscreva se aqui no canal do peão
merece isso nem o piso para 800 mil
inscritos quero que o sexual só indica
não sair
domingo também em itajaí o primeiro link
na descrição que tanto inscrevam merece
inep
só comentei coisas por fazer já em solo
mexicano
não se deixe nunca mais ele foi então
para o corre por fora quer dizer eu
voltar à escola incluindo a gente focar
na óbvia cópia desculpa
[Música]